- Too many people in
their youth want both.
They want to claim that their parents
are full of shit or this is wrong
but they don't want to take the jump
into what they claim and so you want both.
You want to shit on the establishment
but you're not willing to take the risk
to prove if you're good enough.
Then you're full of shit, not them.
(slow electronic music)
You've got your perspective.
(audience cheers)
I just want to be happy.
Don't you want to be happy?
(upbeat electronic music)
If people knew at 22,
eat dick for a decade,
like eat it, like eat it.
Like live with your parents or in a studio
in the Bronx with nine.
If you knew the blueprint
of eat shit for a decade
when it's easy, most people
would be happy at 35.
Patience is your best friend.
You'll win, you're young as fuck.
Build craft, you can't
imagine how young you are.
I couldn't drill it
through your head enough.
Don't put pressure on yourself
which has been created by outside forces.
Whether it's your parents or society
or your homie or your
older or younger sibling
or who the fuck.
Time is your teammate.
When you take time and
make it your teammate
instead of your enemy,
shit gets real interesting.
(slow music)
Storytelling is super interesting.
Whether it's serial or
whether it's me interrupting
my guest for an hour.
Storytelling is interesting.
The thing that people
don't understand about me
is I'm ghetto.
- [Intern] Yeah.
- I'm Rocky I, II and VI.
(intern laughs)
You know?
- [Intern] Yeah, yeah.
- That's who I am.
- [Intern] Okay, okay.
- That's why I win, man.
- [Intern] Yeah.
- Because I'm fucking, like ask.
Alex is looking right now
because I'm fucking yelling
at my team, not yelling.
I mean, it's super love
and he'll tell you.
Because I'm fucking, I'm
texting the team yesterday
on Sunday at 3:00, 4:00, 5:00, 7:00, 9:00
this morning, it's like 8:00, let's go.
Because I'm in it.
- [Intern] Yeah.
- So after you make it,
then the work starts.
- [Intern] Right, right, got it.
- The making is the
wrong thing to focus on.
(soft uplifting music)
Hello, how are you?
Good to see you.
Great, so I'd love for
you to go around the room
and introduce yourself.
Tell me where you're from and
what you've been working on.
Cool, we'll start with that.
(soft music)
Nobody believes that
what they see on video
is who I actually am.
I mean, but that doesn't bother me.
Like that will eventually
be exposed or not.
My wiring and then my
practicing of my wiring
is just like the inability to dwell.
I don't think anybody has control over me.
I never worry about my family.
I never worry about the
government, the President,
any of it, I don't dwell.
I just think I'm in control.
So how do you feel?
How does something feel
insurmountable when you know
in control, I didn't say thought.
Notice, that was even interesting to me.
When you know you're in control.
What are you complaining about?
Fix it.
My biggest thing right now with youth is
do what you want because
if you're appeasing
your parents, you're gonna resent them
and be regretful your whole life and then,
you're not actually have a relationship
with your parents.
I spend all my time looking at old people.
Not young people.
Old people have played
and when old people hate
their old parents because they did
what their parents wanted, I'm like,
"That's wrong, fuck it."
Have the problems now with your parents
for 24, 36, 48 months.
And then, here's the good news.
Then, it's merit.
If you were right that
you're actually a rapper,
not a lawyer, if you
became a successful rapper,
they're gonna be proud as fuck.
If you don't, well then, guess what?
They were right, at least
that you weren't a rapper.
Maybe you're still not
a lawyer, but the merit
of the game will play out.
Too many people in their youth want both.
They want to claim that their parents
are full of shit or this is wrong
but they don't want to take
the jump into what they claim
and so you want both.
You want to shit on the establishment
but you're not willing to take the risk
to prove if you're good enough.
Then you're full of shit, not them.
(soft music)
I don't judge myself.
I feel like I'm trying.
I know what my intent is,
I feel like I'm trying
really hard and my big thing is
before you say something to me,
why don't you look at yourself?
It's really hard for me to get going
like, man, would I love for you all to be
empowered when your parents say something,
to call them out on them
doing the same thing.
That's what parents do.
They impose their thing on you.
Your mom is doing what her mom to her,
even though she hated that
her mom did it to her.
It's how humans work.
I'm a big fan of sleeping
in the bed that you've made.
I got big ambitions, I'm
trying to be out here
doing shit, well, guess what?
Nobody should be crying for me.
So I can't complain.
I fucking put myself out there.
Right, I'm putting myself out there.
I don't have to say yes to the interviews.
I don't have to fucking
be filming my fucking self
24 hours a day.
I made this bed.
I gotta sleep in it, everything
that comes along with it.
And if I do something
fucking stupid or wrong
and I get called out on it,
I need to own that shit.
And I'm okay with that.
Because I don't think I'm perfect.
I'm just trying to stay narrow.
Narrow is my thing, you know?
Stay in my lane.
(soft music)
My job is eating shit.
You know, like everything
is on me, ultimately.
Right?
I have tremendous
perspective and I have no
sustained funk, like even the thought of
a day is out of the question.
Like a full day of being in a funk is
just not gonna happen, it just can't.
There's just nothing that
can happen that makes me
change my mindset of how good we have it.
I mean, if you actually, all of you.
I don't know anything about
you, enough to know this,
but just looking around the room.
The fact that you're sitting in a building
in New York City in America
and have an internship here.
You would probably shit
your pants if there was
a world ranking on quality
of life, happiness.
Just net score of where
do you rank on earth.
Like a new system came out.
It took everything into account.
It brain scanned you for
happiness, depression,
all of it.
What is your net rank in the world?
You would be humbled by
how good your life is.
I don't think you have a perspective.
I don't think anybody
does and I'm not even sure
I do, I just try my
best to think about this
kind of almost daily.
Where do you rank out
of 7.7 billion people?
The answer for a lot of
you is outrageously high.
(soft music)